[Musique]
what our two qui a suivi les capsules
spatiales arrive pour la première fois
sur la terre enfin pour l'instant il en
est encore à découvrir la mer
[Musique]
oui
comme il n'a jamais rencontré deux oies
il décide de les suivre pour les
regarder vivre
[Musique]
quelle étrange petit oiseau
un peu plus tard au palais présidentiel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
what what ont à peine trois petits à
nice
[Musique]
après la réception officielle les deux
astronautes et le président sont salués
par la foule
tiens la famille zoua
[Musique]
bah voilà tout aux oies au bois quel
comédien ses villas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ils sont amusants sa seule planète tout
compte fait
[Musique]
ok
allez va faire comme eux
[Musique]
et vous le circuit
[Rires]
[Musique]
mais qu'est ce que c'est étrange petit
animal oh mon dieu ou à toi tout a volé
le crès de chiens du président
[Musique]
oh mais non ouattara tous voulaient tout
simplement offrir le crès de chien la
famille soit ça c'est gentil
et maintenant le grand jeu les oies toi
tu ouvres sont transformés en quoi
regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et oui les boîtes on va tous se
transforme en pluie d'or
[Musique]
je m'appelle voit tout va tout et je
vois tout à bientôt
lui
et